The last issue is what's called drift,
okay.
Drift is the error that happens
that accumulates over time.
That basically what happens is you've
got this dynamic model that's making
a prediction and, and you've got
its censored observation model etc.
And you're really caught
with two choices, okay, and
both of the choices are lousy.
Choice one is,
I stick to my target model, right?
I really believe the model.
And I never change it, like its
appearance, it's colored up just.
The problem with that is what
happens if the object is changing?
All of a sudden, you know,
it goes in the trees, shadows,
things look a little different,
and I didn't update my model.
So, almost every tracker does
some form of model update.
The problem with that is
when you do model update,
you run into situation like this, okay?
So this is actually taken from
the Tracking People paper,
although this was, they were
explaining how not to do tracking.
So they've got this little box that's
stuck on the middle of the ice skater.
And each time they're updating
something about the description, and
eventually the box slides down.
And what's not shown here is,
it might get stuck on the background
markings in the, in the rink.
And so what's happening is you keep
changing, changing, changing and
all of the sudden more of the mark,
of the target model came from
the rink than came from the skaters.
So as the skater leaves,
the model stays right there.
And this is the,
the problem with adaptive tracking.
And so all real tracking,
in order to fight drift,
always has this balance between how
quickly or how much do I change
my model versus how much do I
keep what I had from before.
And you might ask, well,
how come I didn't see any of this in
all that Bayesian stuff that you did?
The reason is, I gave you
the sensor model, P of z given x.
And I really didn't tell you
how it behaves generically, or
I should say, all the time.
It just, we, we in fact, all we did
was we generically gave the algorithm.
P of z given x might be how
well do I match the pixels.
Well, but if the pixels are changing,
I have to change my sensor model.
So that's the place in the algorithm
where that notion of how well do I
hold onto my old model versus change it.
That's the place where it stays.